-Hey, guys, I'm here
with Dwayne Johnson.
We're about to head over to
"The Tonight Show" ride.
Along the way, we're gonna play
Race Though Universal Studios,
starring Dwayne Johnson
and Jimmy Fallon.
-Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-The rules are as follows.
If you get a high five
from anyone
in the park, that's one point.
If you get a hug,
that's the three points.
If you get a photo,
like a selfie,
that's five points.
-Five big ones.
-We'll each have a judge
calculating the points,
and the person with the most
points in three minutes wins.
You ready?
-Let's do this.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-[ Laughs ]
♪♪
-Five, four, three, two, one.
-Dwayne had 103 points.
-Jimmy had 111 points.
-Aw.
-Yes!
♪♪
Yes, yes!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Hey, while we have this on,
you want to go upstairs
and photobomb some people?
-Um, what's that term?
Hell yes.
-Let's do it. Let's do it.
♪♪
We're backstage at
the "Tonight Show," right?
People think they're about
to take their picture taken
onstage at the ride,
but we're going to surprise them
by photobombing them as...
-Us, kind of.
-As us, but they don't know
that it's -- that it's us.
-Yeah.
-It's us.
It's all four of us.
-Yeah.
-All right, get ready.
Let's do this.
-Let's do it.
-Big smiles.
Look right down this lens.
Big, big, big smiles.
Three, two, one.
[ Camera shutter clicks ]
-Did we get that shot?
[ Laughter ]
Did we get it?
-Oh! That's crazy.
-Oh!
-Did we get it?
Did we get it?
-He's using the dab.
A dab is...
-There you go.
-Three, two, one.
[ Camera shutter clicks ]
-Did we get it?
-Whew, yeah.
-Oh, my goodness!
-Did we get the shot?
-Hello.
-Hi.
-I have the shirt.
-You called it. You called it.
-A little cheesy.
-You called it.
[ Laughter ]
-Husband,
you're not watching this.
-Switch?
You want to twerk?
-Let's do it.
-Let's twerk.
-And three, two, one.
[ Camera shutter clicks ]
-Three, two, one.
-Did we get the shot?
-Phew! What's up, dude?
-Oh, my God.
-Did we get the...
Did we get the picture?
-No tears. No tears.
-I think we got it, my dude.
[ Laughter ]
Nice to meet you.
-I think we got the photo, man.
-[ Laughs ]
Oh, my God, look at that, dude.
-Dude's got a tattoo of you
on his leg.
-Oh, my...
-Come in here.
Let's get a shot.
-Three, two, one.
[ Camera shutter clicks ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I'm Steve Higgins,
ad we're about to play
a game called Phone Booth.
Our first player this evening
is the host
of "The Tonight Show,"
Mr. Jimmy Fallon.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And Jimmy's opponent, the star
of "The Fate of the Furious,"
Mr. Dwayne Johnson!
[ Cheers and applause ]
The rules of the game
are simple --
when you get a question wrong,
a stranger
from the mystery bench
gets shoved into your booth.
The first question
is for Mr. Jimmy Fallon.
[ Imitates push-buttons
beeping ]
[ Telephone rings ]
-[ Gravelly voice ]
Hello? I just woke up.
-I'm sorry, did --
did I wake you?
-Yeah, sorry, what's up, man?
-Oh, I'm sorry.
I have a question for you.
Is this Mr. Jimmy Fallon?
-[ Clears throat, normal voice ]
Yeah, hey, it's me.
-Okay, what drink was
invented --
-What drink?
-What drink --
not mini drink,
regular drink --
was invented at the
University of Florida in 1965,
and is named
after the school's mascot?
What is your answer?
-I know this. This is easy.
Gatorade.
-That is correct.
[ Ding ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
That means joining
Dwayne's booth
is a CERN ATLAS ambassador
who's been called
the next Einstein.
Please welcome
7-year-old genius
Romanieo Golphin, Jr.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hi, buddy, how you doing?
-Great.
-Handshake. What a gentleman.
-There we go.
He's filling his booth.
-What -- What is that there?
-Don't you worry about that one.
Get back in your booth.
The next question is for Dwayne.
Just cool it.
[ Imitates push-buttons
beeping ]
Yeah, he gets a child genius.
[ Telephone rings ]
-Excuse me for a second.
Your dime, my time.
Why don't you tell me
what's on your sweet mind?
[ Laughter ]
-Dwayne, I have
a question for you.
-Okay.
-What type of rock is formed
from solidified lava or magma?
-Excuse me one second.
-Igneous.
-What?
-That answer would be igneous.
-Yes, it is.
[ Ding ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, that means
joining Jimmy's booth
is seven-time world champion,
from "Monday Night RAW,"
make some room
for WWE superstar Big Show!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hey, how's it going?
-How are you?
-Hi! Hello, beautiful.
-How you doing, fella?
-We're about to get
really close.
-Get in here.
-Oh, hi, Jimmy, hi.
[ Laughter ]
-There you go!
-Oh, my gosh.
Good to see you, buddy.
You look great, man.
-Good to see you, too.
-Everything going great?
Is there any other
kid geniuses back there?
Okay.
-All right.
[ Laughing ]
Next question is for Jimmy.
-This is insane.
[ Telephone rings ]
Yeah, can you get that?
-Mr. Fallon's phone.
Can I help you?
Uh, just one moment, please.
For you, sir.
-Thank you, Big. Hello.
-Jimmy?
-Yes.
-According to a recent study,
what part of a man's body
sweats the most?
-[ Laughs ]
-It's a family show.
Remember it's a family show.
-I think I know
this one as well.
I would say the armpit.
-Ooh, that is wrong!
[ Buzzer ]
-What?
[ Audience groans ]
-The correct answer is the back.
So, joining Jimmy's booth...
-You're so smart.
-...from their show
right here
at Universal Orlando,
please welcome
The Blue Man Group.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Come on in, fellas.
We'll make room.
-[ Mumbles ]
-Got enough air in there?
Are you good?
-I'm so glad I lost weight.
-Oh, good gosh.
-Get in there!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hi, guys, nice to see you.
-Oh, boy.
-All right.
[ Audience "Aww"s ]
The next question...
[ Laughter ]
This is for Dwayne.
-There's a -- there's a --
there's a Blue Man gone rogue.
-What's that?
-There's a Blue Man gone rogue.
-He'll be okay.
-He wants to go in the Rock's --
You can't tell him what to do.
-He'll be okay.
Don't worry about it.
-You can't tell him --
-You worry about your own booth.
I'm gonna call Dwayne.
-Yeah.
[ Telephone rings ]
Excuse me one sec.
Okay. All right.
Y-You're creeping out the kid.
[ Laughter ]
Hello?
-Dwayne?
-Yes.
-How many planets
in our solar system have rings?
-I know.
-Excuse me.
-Don't ask that kid.
Don't -- Don't tell him.
Don't tell him.
-CERN-certified genius.
-Don't tell that kid.
-The answer would be four.
-That is correct.
[ Ding ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Jupiter, Neptune, Saturn,
and Uranus.
-Big Show, you gotta
help me out.
-The last planet is Uranus.
Now, joining Jimmy's booth --
I'm good.
Please welcome the
Mayor of Orlando, Buddy Dyer.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Hop right in.
Just shove a hand
near Jimmy's face.
-Oh! Oh!
-Oh, good gracious.
Oh, boy.
-I just got blue.
[ Alarm blares ]
-We all know what
that sound means.
-What? Game over?
-No, we've plenty more game.
-Hi, Mr. Mayor.
-It's time for the final call.
-You look tight in there.
-Yeah, thank you.
-The winner of this
next question
gets to shove everyone else
from the mystery bench...
-You've got this, Jimmy!
-...into [laughs] their
opponent's booth.
Let us bring out
the mystery bench --
two of our favorite Minions,
Tom and Stuart.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
All right, this final question
is for Jimmy.
-Oh, boy, I hope
we get this right.
-[ Imitates push-button
beeping ]
[ Telephone rings ]
-Can someone get that for me?
-I'm the phone guy.
-Thank you, buddy. Hello?
-Jimmy, can you hear me?
-How did you get this number?
[ Laughter ]
-This is the final question.
How many seconds
are there in one day?
-What is Dwayne's phone number?
Can I use call waiting?
-No, you may not.
-It's that kid genius.
-You may not phone a friend.
-How many seconds --
-How many seconds in a day?
-One of the blue men are moving.
[ Slide whistle ]
-Thank you.
One of the blue men are moving.
-Oh, time is up.
-Okay.
-The correct answer was 86,400.
I'm sorry.
[ Buzzer ]
-Yeah, we were gonna say that.
Thank you very much.
86,396.
-That means Dwayne wins.
Let's get our winners out here.
[ Bell dinging ]
Let's see how many people
you can shove in Jimmy's booth.
-Shove them in.
Help me shove this one in.
-This is gonna be brutal.
-Shove them in.
-Oh, no.
-[ Laughs ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Speaking indistinctly ]
Stuart, Stuart, get over here.
Guys, our thanks to
Dwayne Johnson,
Romanieo Golphin, Jr.,
Big Show, The Blue Man Group,
Mayor Buddy Dyer,
and the Minions!
Gotta ask -- how did you
get in such great shape
for "Hercules"?
-It's actually a funny story.
You know, about a year ago,
I found this old VHS tape
in my basement,
and it had a bunch of clips
of this fitness duo
called The Fungo Brothers.
-Oh, I remember
the Fungo Brothers.
-Yeah.
-Yeah, they had this --
they were really
ahead of their time.
[ Laughter ]
All the fitness --
No, you don't -- all the fitness
trends over the years,
the Thigh Master,
Shake Weight --
these guys did it first.
They were never...
[ Laughter ]
...quite successful,
but they were always so close
to the next big thing.
It's amazing they never got
credit for it.
-I know! It's crazy.
-Actually, you know what?
We have access to a database
of a bunch of clips of the
fitness tapes and everything.
NBC archives has
on a hard drive --
we might have a clip
of those guys.
-Oh, cool.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Uh, let's check it out.
-Yeah.
-Computer...
[ Laughter ]
[ Accent ] Computer,
search "Fungo Brothers."
[ Normal voice ] I don't know
why you have to do it
in that accent.
-Well, it's important.
-Oh.
-It's important.
-It found a clip.
-Oh.
-Let's take a look.
[ Cheesy music playing ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Hi!
[ Cheers and applause ]
I'm Jeff Fungo.
-And I'm Tad Fungo.
-Do you want to run faster?
Do you want your legs
that will cause disaster
and glutes that are harder
than plaster?
You gotta get
the Thigh Cruncher.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You'll know it's working --
you'll know it's working
when you feel the burn
between your legs.
[ Audience cheering ]
-The-- these are really hard.
[ Laughter ]
-You gotta -- and --
and remember --
-You gotta hustle
for the muscle!
-I'm cramping up.
-You okay?
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Almost...
-[ Laughs ] Wow.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-It was almost a Thigh Master
but not quite.
-No, I mean, they were so close.
-Yeah.
What -- What's with the blanket?
[ Laughter ]
-It's just --
it's just a little chilly
in here in the studio sometimes,
just want to cover up.
-I understand.
You haven't had candy
since 1989.
-I d-- Oh.
-And it was --
And it was a Twizzler.
-It was a Twizzler, yes.
I'm just --
Hey, Twizzler fans out there.
-Yeah, exactly.
-I'm just not a big candy guy,
you know?
I love cheat meals, right?
I love that.
But I'm just not, like,
a candy thing. I'm just...
-You never go, like,
to a 7-Eleven,
and right at the counter you go,
"I'll just take that," or...?
-No, I've never -- No, no.
-No, never done that?
-No, no, never did that.
But, no, literally,
it's crazy how I remember
this kind of stuff, right?
It's like "Rain Man."
So I -- It's like Twizzlers
was the last thing I had.
And we were at a movie theater
watching a movie.
-Exactly. Really?
And do you remember
what movie you were seeing?
-I don't remember
what movie I saw.
-But you haven't had candy since
that, so I thought maybe
it's kind of fun
and maybe I could tempt you
to make
a little history tonight.
I mean...
-Oh. Wait a second.
-They still make Twizzlers.
-Hey! [ Chuckles ]
-I got -- I got Ring Pops.
-Wow.
-I got a Ring Pops here,
I got Nerds on a rope.
I mean, you haven't seen
this type --
This candy wasn't even out
in 1989.
This is fantastic.
I have a gummy worm.
All you have to have
is just one gummy worm.
-[ Laughs ] Wow.
Well, I mean, you tempt me.
Look at that.
-Come on, dude.
-You guys know.
-Come on.
This is -- I mean --
-Oh, go ahead.
You...
[ Band plays suggestive music ]
-No, no. No, no, no.
[ Speaking indistinctly ]
-What? Oh, no. Oh, a gummy worm.
-One of those gummy worms,
like...
-Oh, oh, you eat it.
-You eat it.
Yeah, I don't know what
you were doing there.
Gummy worm.
It's a gummy worm.
-Wow.
-I can't tempt you
with anything at all?
-Look, I mean, we're here.
It's -- you know, big movie
comes out, right, tomorrow.
I think we bust open
the Twizzlers
and we have the Twizzlers
right here.
-Let's do it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-There you go, buddy.
-All right.
-Oh, you know what I thought
would be kind of fun?
-Tell me, what do you
want to do?
-I have Pop Rocks.
-"101 Dalmatians"?
-I have Pop Rocks here.
You ever have Pop Rocks?
-Oh, yeah, let's do that.
-This is for
"Central Intelligence."
The movie is coming out
tomorrow.
-Here we go.
-I'm going to put it in your --
I'll pour it, and then I'll just
mic you there.
-Okay, here we go.
Here we go. Here we go.
-But close your eyes.
[ Both laugh ]
Dude, you were -- I was going to
say, I guarantee you, though --
I tell you right now.
No, I'm not gonna put
the gummy worm in your mouth.
-Hey!
-No, I'm not.
-Wait, no!
-I'm putting it away
I'm putting it away.
-That's good.
-By the way...
-Wow.
-...I didn't even think twice
that this was that.
I mean, I am very
Irish Catholic.
-Here we go.
This is the beginning
of a fun night.
-But, actually,
this looks more familiar.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
Put this -- I'll put
this over here.
Fell out of my --
Fell out of my gym bag.
All right. I'll go first.
Oh, here you are.
-Right, here we go. All right.
-Here you go.
This is the Rock
having Pop Rocks.
-Okay.
-Here you go, buddy.
All right.
[ Popping ]
Yeah, it's working.
-It's working.
-It works.
How's it feel?
-So that's what candy
tastes like.
Wow. It's amazing.
-All right.
-It's great.
[ Popping ]
-You hear it?
Yeah.
-Weird, right?
-Weird.
-That's candy.
-Since 1989.
-This is history right here.
Thank you, buddy.
I appreciate that.
-Thank you for that.
-Yeah, let's talk
about this movie.
-Gummy worm! Open --
-No, no, no, no!
-No, no, sorry.
[ Laughs ]
-That was my stripper name.
[ Both laugh ]
-Gummy worm!
-Give it up for Gummy Worm!
Nothing like that.
It was the actual size.
-I think that, you know,
if we ever have the opportunity
to give back to our troops,
I think we all should because,
you know, we're --
we live and enjoy the life
we have, right...
-Yeah.
-...because of them.
So, there is one more thing
I wanted to do
before I left tonight, Jimmy.
So, I would love to give back
to a military family
that's actually here
in the audience.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's so nice.
-I mean, so, if you would
do me a favor.
If you would come with me.
-Sure, of course.
-You guys want to do this?
-Yeah!
-Let's do it.
-All right.
All right, let's do this.
-Do they know --
Do we know who it is?
-They do not know.
-They do not know, no.
This person does not know,
and I'm going to walk over here
in the audience, and let's see.
-This is...
-I'm going to walk up here.
-Is this -- Yep.
-Let's see.
-It's not -- nope.
He's laughing too much.
You're laughing way too much.
-He's laughing way too much.
Yeah. Is it him? No.
-No, no.
Let's see. Are you -- No.
-Is this...
-I don't see this person.
-They're not here?
No, no.
-It's a good-looking crowd.
I will say that.
-Yeah, it's a very...
-Right?
-Very good-looking audience.
[ Cheers and applause ]
They're not here?
-Not here. No, no, no.
I'm going to go up here.
Let's see.
Really good-looking crowd,
though.
Let's see. Uh...
-Here?
-Hi. Hello.
Hello. Oh, wow.
-Hey. How are you?
Is it...
-She was reaching for me
for a second.
-Yeah, she was reaching.
I saw her.
Yeah. I saw her reaching.
-She was reaching.
-I saw her reaching. Yeah.
-[ Laughs ]
-Let's see.
-I saw her reaching.
-You know what?
-Is it here?
-I don't see this person
up here. Let's go back here.
Let's go back here.
Thank you.
Okay. Watch these steps.
I'm going to open this door.
-Sure.
-All right. Here we go.
-Okay.
-Let's see.
-Right in here?
-I think right in here.
Where's Carina?
-Get in there.
-What is happening right now?
[ Laughs ]
What's going on?
-Hi. So...
-Hi.
-So, you're Carina?
-Yeah.
-Yeah, you're Carina.
And I hear you're a producer
of the show,
and you're an Army vet.
-I am.
-Right.
My name is, um,
[softly] Dwayne Johnson.
-What is happening?
-[ Normal voice ] How you doing?
-Hi.
-It's so good to meet you.
And I heard
that you met your husband
when you were both
deployed in Iraq.
-Yeah.
-Ah, okay.
And your husband's name is Todd?
-Yeah. [ Laughs ]
-Yeah.
And he's a master sergeant
in the U.S. Air Force.
-He is. [ Laughs ]
-Right? Yeah.
Absolutely.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And you guys
have been living apart
for the past year and a half
because he's 5,000 miles away.
So, Carina, what Jimmy and I
wanted to do for you --
we just wanted to thank you
and your husband
for your service
and your sacrifice,
and I personally heard that
you're the most amazing person,
and we wanted to
bring your husband home
for you in the holidays.
Turn around
and hug your husband.
-What? Oh, my God!
-Hey, babe.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
-Surprise!
-Oh, man. [ Laughs ]
I'm losing it right now.
I'm losing it.
Come on.
Group hug, group hug.
-Group hug.
-Thank you for everything.
-What?!
[ Laughter ]
-How did you even do this
without me knowing?
-We love you, pal.
We love you.
-What?
-You guys, my thanks to Todd.
Thank you, Carina.
Thank you to Dwayne Johnson.